lancement officiel de campagne pour le
maire d'elancourt dans la 11e
circonscription face à la presse en
cette fin mars jean michel fourgous
annoncé partir à la reconquête d'un
poste occupé de 1993 à 1997 puis de 2002
à 2012 axes principaux de sa campagne
l'emploi la sécurité et l'éducation
ces trois sujets sur lequel bien entendu
il ya beaucoup d'armes et trash qui
dépendent de national donc c'est pour ça
que j'y vais j'ai déjà des reins un
groupe de 150 députés qui s'appelle
génération entreprises dont je suis le
porte parole
j'ai écrit déjà vingt propositions donc
bien sûr j'ai envie de les mettre en
place et droite donc donc ces prêts
ainsi demain je suis député mais j'ai
fait comment ça va vite parce que tout
est prêt le candidat de la droite et du
centre pourrait affronter le sortant
benoît hamon reste à connaître les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
dans laquelle ce dernier s'est engagé en
2012 il l'avait emporté sur cette
circonscription qui couvre notamment les
communes de bois d'arcy elancourt la
verrière le mesnil saint denis ou encore
trappe avec 55% des voix
il est trop dans la triche ce garçon il
a la culture de la triche sur ses
diplômes sur les eaux sales femmes sur
sur son habitation sur sur sur l'emploi
sur il a dit qu'il avait fait ça vous
vérifié c'est pas assez un autre qu'il a
fait il s'attribue le travail des autres
c'est compliqué c'est un garçon qui pose
un problème je trouve moins de confiance
également candidats déjà déclarés dans
cette circonscription luc miserait élu
communiste d'opposition attrape ou
encore mathilde andrew est élu front
national au conseil régional